[Applause]
sherilyn jesse each darn shows that deal
with awkward situations Jesse and modern
family and cherylin Kirby enthusiasm so
eighth and I also heard Cheryl loves
game nights so yes it's very fun so we
thought we'd see how they and I deal
with uncomfortable social situations in
real life it's time to play Oh a that's
awkward it's pretty simple will hand
this button then an awkward situation
will appear with a couple options on how
to deal with it we have or we each have
rather to say which option we choose in
each situation so here we go I kind of
don't understand it either but it's
gonna be okay so we're gonna push the
button does it matter who pushes the
button can anybody push it I'm gonna
push the button do it okay oh now you
push the violin okay so your boss calls
you by the wrong name do you a corrector
be become a new person like oh hi Tina
hello yes I like that name
my real name is Jesse Tyler Moore but
Eric Stonestreet called me Jesse Tyler
Ferguson so I just went with that I
think I think I would just get it out of
the way right away yeah I would have to
correct
because I can't people think my name is
Jeffy I was like Jesse's not a name is
it yeah sometimes people just see or
like the real name like yeah sometimes
people say Clarkston yeah and I'm like
so that's not that's not
I feel like Ryan actually said that when
I want American Idol I was like did he
seek Larsen okay I guess I do role in it
I roll with it that's what I do
all right next Siri you want to hit it
go ahead that's the role that's a school
I got this down okay oh no I think we
hit it and then it goes it oh oh you hit
the button you do not have it
[Laughter]
all right a person exits a stall in a
public restroom with toilet paper
hanging from surface do you a tell them
or B start whistling avoid eye-contact
quickly wash your hands and exit that's
wrong do you need to tell someone would
you not why I had a situation when it
was there was a woman in the bathroom
and she came out she had a law even it
was long paper trail and I said how does
that happen
don't ask and I said excuse me but
you've got some toilet paper hanging and
she said oh can you get it
[Applause]
like Larry David mode and I was like no
I can't my friend was like you should
have made oven mitts out of toilet paper
and yeah that um I meant a lot to and it
definitely said hard pass on that one
yeah
is it bad that I would get a lot of Glee
out of going out to being an someone be
like you have toilet paper coming out of
your pain yeah yeah hey girl I'm totally
the person to tell you if you have a
booger your zippers down I'm like here
yeah I understand if that happens to me
or I get you know right off stage from
presenting an award or something and
I've like spinach or said well or some
type of sugar it's not something in my
teeth those are jerks yeah I'm gonna
touched her toilet paper I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this